- Did she give you any
like motherhood advice?
- Well, I got to see her be a mom.
That's how I learned to be a mom.
But my
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- little nugget shocked me
and she came almost six weeks early
when I wasn't in New York,
which is where I live.
I was in Maine.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I woke up at four in the
morning, and I went into labor,
and all of a sudden I'm
googling hospitals nearby.
- What?
- And we made it.
- I would've been terrified.
- Yes.
- I mean I was, but I didn't
know what was ahead of me.
So, it was sort of,
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- the unknown, I didn't know.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, we made it.
She arrived like, an hour after
we arrived at the hospital.
And she had to be in the
NICU for the first four weeks
and we were totally unprepared.
We thought she was gonna come
on her due date.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So my sister, luckily, flew
to Maine, went to Target,
- [Kelly] Ooh, where you can get it all.
- got everything.
- Oh yeah, I got,
and by the way, I know what to get.
I'm like, okay
- [Kelly] Yeah.
yes to the Aquaphor.
- Yeah.
- Yes to the diapers.
- Yeah, like
the diapers,
- Yes.
- the car seat, we had no
means of taking her home
from the hospital.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So, I don't know that
she gave me advice,
but she just stepped up and
helped me get that little nugget
through her first few months of life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And her name is Cora Georgia Coyne.
- [Kelly] Awe.
- Georgia after my dad and grandfather.
So, my dad just calls her, C. George.
- C George.
It's like she's learning
to read. See George run.
- [Barbara] She doesn't know what,
- See George,
- Yes,
George play.
- Walk.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, she doesn't know what to answer to.
- Yeah.
- But all of their grandkids call them,
my dad's nickname is Jefe,
which means the boss in Spanish.
- [Kelly] Okay.
I like that.
- Which was a
self chosen
- It's self-appointed, yeah.
- He chose it.
- [Jenna] Yes. He's like,
- It wasn't like a
little grandchild was like,
- [Jenna] No.
- I'm gonna call you Jefe.
He chosen in advance,
and now has taught them
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Jenna] Basically,
- [Barbara] that.
- he was in retirement
and nobody was calling
him the boss anymore.
- So he was, yeah.
- So he's like, hey you.
- [Kelly] It was a power struggle,
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] within.
- A little bit.
- Yeah. I love that.
I want, that's a cool name.